[Music]
I'm such a fan and was so anxious to
read this book that I got a copy of it
about a month before it came out and
read it and you have read about you have
lived about fifty five lifetimes I think
absolutely incredible stories here one
of my favorites though I witnessed
personally it's not in the book I don't
know if you remember this Andy but
Allman Brothers Band played our
late-night show in 1995 you guys came on
and just before you came on the guest
was Johnny Rotten from the Sex Pistols
and there he is and he came on and he
was saying things just to try and be
outrageous and he started trashing the
Allman Brothers Band started talking
about you guys and saying very negative
things and apparently backstage you and
dickey betts jumped up and said what
still get that English fella and started
running around looking for him he found
out that you were looking for him he
after in the commercial break ran out of
the studio and fled the building would
you guys have beat him up and if you had
caught him nothing like a good set of
fisticuffs every now we're also familiar
with your music
I'm just curious on a personal level I
listen to that music that you recorded
with with your band with your brother at
the Fillmore it's so iconic now can you
listen to that music now and connect to
that time you can you don't just hear it
as music now you can you can connect to
that's my I'm playing with my brother
this is our band this is us playing that
gig get real quiet you don't headphones
that's the only way to listen to music
headphones you can listen to it and you
can hear and is it an emotional
experience for you your brother's been
gone for so long now Dwayne is it an
emotional experience for you to listen
to your brother play it's yeah it's all
kind of different emotions because you
get it real quiet you put on these
headphones and you get comfortable and
lean back and just listen to it and I
mean you know the songs like come to a
pinnacle and then they'll smooth
that you know I mean the songs are like
real winners the performance is very
very good and so it it starts off with
Bill Graham saving them rounded all
rounded off with the best of them all
Diamond Brothers yeah and many people
who are at that show you can hear on the
recording say it's the best live music
they have ever heard in their life
that's a little steep I just made that
up
by the way stormy Monday for years that
was the song I used to get the ladies in
the mood all right really stormy Monday
you wander off that album of the film or
you all lived in this big house in Macon
and we're talking late 60s you live
together and you didn't have much money
and you're putting the band together and
this was a crazy insane house where lots
of crazy things happened and it's just
basically a frat house but to the tenth
degree now they have turned that house
into a museum and you've gone back
what's it like to go back to that house
where all this madness happened and
they've turned it into a museum oh yes
they have the damn house was like a
hundred years old when we rented it
right and that was back in the 70s early
70s and so to refurbish it man you just
about have to Jack with Jack that one up
and roll a new one under it yeah I mean
you got a so well the foundation needs
to be replaced
well they mean you read the book it's
not like they had to boil it for a while
that just says how it had to be steam
clean before they could let people come
into it oh it's funny to you now it's
all in the booklet it's pretty nice